je sais pas si vous avez fait attention
mais ça fait quelques semaines que je
vous poste sur instagram des photos de
machine à laver de lave linge je sèche
par le fait qu'on pourrait dire pourquoi
est ce que monsieur grehan parlant de
tech nous parle de lave linge sale et
bien justement la technologie est
partout et notamment dans des lave linge
on la retrouve beaucoup dans les
smartphones je parle beaucoup de choses
que j'aime beaucoup c'est un produit qui
m'intéresse beaucoup et justement je
vous parle également de lave linge
aujourd'hui pourquoi parce que il ya un
vrai sens où il est venu me chercher
maison monsieur greu on voudrait
collaborer avec toi pour parler de notre
nouveau lave-linge suprême caire j'ai
accepté parce que pour moi ça a un sens
vous est pas tout dit déçu que ça
[Musique]
j'ai pas si mal vu cette photo là
regardez là comme j'ai l'air the end
directement sur mon linge de whirlpool
il ya eu aussi des photos là on re le
tout la partie commandes du lab
l'honneur écoutez je vous explique
justement pourquoi je vous parle de la
plage quand vient le pool m'a contacté
et m'ont dit monsieur grenet moi faire
de nos qu'avec toi on aimerait présenter
notre nouvelle machine suprême caire qui
est axé autour du silence autour de côté
zen autour d'un environnement silencieux
calmes chez soi est ce que certains
thales et je me suis dit ça tombe plutôt
bien
et justement pour moi c'est un vrai sens
pourquoi pas c'est quelque chose que je
vous ai pas montré regardez les brader
quoi on va déjà fait cette caméra là à
lévis up tac que vous montez en tout que
je vous ai jamais montré c'est les
coulisses de mon studio ici en bas de
chez moi alors je sais juste à côté de
chez moi je suis juste en dessous de
chez moi
et s'il faut savoir c'est que ici c'est
mon studio de ce côté là mais c'est
également une pièce de vie de la maison
vous allez voir les regarder donc là
vous avez le décor que vous connaissez
vous savez il ya ma bécane qui est juste
à côté
et là on va choisir on va suivre n'est
petite porte alors attendez je décale
l'éclairage là vous avez une porte et
cette porte là elle ment mais nous elle
m'emmène ici directement au niveau du
lave linge avant justement pour le coup
une machine qui ne fait pas de bruit une
machine qu'est silencieuse ça pour moi
c'est vraiment important parce que vous
voyez on est quand même vraiment à côté
j'ai le studio le lave-linge le
lave-linge le studio le studio le lave
linge lave linge le studio et comme je
tourne tous les jours et comme je
travaille tous les jours il ya un moment
où le lave-linge va potentiellement
tourné au moment où moi je travaille
avec le lave-linge qu'on avait avant ici
non non non non non non tu attends on
discute en famille on dit orange peuvent
faire tourner la page et non non non pas
maintenant là je fais tourner ma vidéo
dans deux ans le temps que j'ai bien
tout calé à ce moment-là on pourra le
faire mais pas avant parce que sinon ça
va pas le faire ça va faire du bruit et
notamment les volets sont rage ça va
brasser tout début ça va pas le faire je
distribue l'idée d'avoir une machine qui
ne fait pas du tout de bruit c'est
vraiment bien si fait que je peux lancer
une petite machine
je peux tout en même temps vous ne le
savez pas c'est déjà arrivé plusieurs
fois
eh bien vous ne le savez pas donc ça
c'est vraiment être c'est un vrai
confort alors ici vous parle de
conditions studio mais imaginez chez
vous je sais pas comment c'était chez
vous alors si vous avez une grande
maison avec une pièce pour la buanderie
il se peut effectivement qu' il n'y ait
pas de nuisances au niveau sonore mais
imagine
vous ayez par exemple une seule grande
pièce de vie pourra pas une cuisine
ouverte et que votre lave-linge soit
c'est possible ça rime en fonction des
configurations des appartements et bien
ce moment là c'est un vrai bonheur
d'avoir un lave linge qui fait
absolument pas de bruit un côté zen
donc ça pour moi combien de poule est
venu me proposer ça c'est une superbe
opportunité d'une de poids vous en
parler et de deux d'avoir un lave linge
qui te fait absolument pas de bruit si
vous montrez pas ce que nous ici on
équipe est totalement envahie poule
c'est pas suite à des partenariats
camatte
c'est nous à titre personnel on acheter
de nouvelles pompes pour la cuisine je
connaissais déjà là bas je sais que
c'est une marque qui gage de qualité
donc j'ai dit ça sans aucun partenariat
redécouvre une poule pour tous cas les
premiers âges et de la cuisine
donc je connaissais la marque on se dit
ok je sais que c'est de la bonne qualité
puisque les poulets sont cool donc c'est
plutôt bien d'avoir une assise campus ne
fait absolument pas bruit regardez
aujourd'hui parce que j'ai pris j'ai ici
ma manière de linge sale
on va aller se faire tourner ça il ya
vraiment besoin de laver le linge vous
allez voir c'est extrêmement bluffant on
va revenir se poser juste à côté ici la
machine tournant je veux laisser ouvrir
la porte
vous verrez cette femme absolument au
cameroun c'est vraiment impressionnant
c'est très bizarre de venir sont
décisives pas particulièrement
l'habitude de me donner vos images
alors regardez comme âge où tout ça à
faire entrer là dedans
[Musique]
première chose ça déjà faciles à
manipuler facile aware c'est plutôt cool
mais surtout ce qui est très
intéressante cette machine c'est les
différents modes de leur acheter ou
alors je vais pas vous faire un topo
aujourd'hui sur les différents modes de
l'os mais vous allez voir le truc est
très facile très simple d'utilisation ça
marche bien c'est très pratique
complètement tactile top technologie
bienvenus en fait vous avez plusieurs
modes vous venez les choisir directement
ici vous voyez coton échos du coton
mixte c'est ce que j'utilise moi c'est
très pratique synthétique délicat yens
couleurs rapide 30 minutes rinçage
essorage essorage vidange et la pile
bouton
moi je me mets ici en mixte 55 minutes
ces pratiques sixième sens vous appuyer
là ça calcule tout seul ça marche tout
seul on si nous allions température
alors moi je vis ici en 40 degrés pour
éviter de tout cramer succès du mixte ça
marche très très bien ça va bien hop
vous choisissez ensuite votre nombre de
tours par minute pour les sauvages 1400
tours par minute je sais je sois
personnage mais ça marche très très bien
et après vous pouvez revenir dessus
température vous choisissez vos ouailles
dans combien de temps ces prêts ça vous
le marquis si vous pouvez avoir une et
dosage si vous voulez vous avez pas mal
d'options fraîcheur du tambour couleurs
15 vous avez différentes jauges vous
devez venir verrouiller les touches si
vous avez des enfants que voulait pas
qu'ils fassent des bêtises
une fois tout et qu'il était prêt il
vous reste plus qu'à venir aux vins un
tiroir à venir mettre ici vote
détergents votre adoucissant et c'est
parti
[Musique]
si vous vous rendez compte là en fait je
suis juste à côté
c'est en train de tourner on n'entend
absolument rien y a pas plus de 66 des
six bacs est vraiment silencieux que ça
ne fait absolument pas de bruit vasella
elle tourne est ce que vous attendez
quelque chose et c'est vraiment ça qui
m'a laissé sur cette opération
le fait d'avoir cette machine là qui
tourne là moi qui tourne différemment à
côté c'est vraiment cool retour ce quota
dans le studio jeu quand même mieux si
le décor est quand même plus sympa même
si la machine est très joli mais on est
quand même un peu plus tranquille
écoutez mise à part ce vieux tabouret
kinross vous vous dites qu à côté vous
avez un lave linge est en train de
tourner et qui est en train de se
remplir qui en train d'avoir un cycle
est absolument rien au clash entre ed
rush sur le studio mais imaginez vous
êtes chez vous il ya volume en cas de
oui c'est vraiment l'idée en fait de
cela plein c'est de se dire vous
profiter de moments calmes de moments de
sérénité demande vous avez pas de
pollution vous n'êtes pas embêtés je
déteste être embêté par des pollutions
extérieures je déteste avoir trop de
bruit quand je suis chez moi quand je
suis chez moi ce que je veux c'est
couper toute la journée on court toute
la journée il ya des événements il ya
des choses il ya du travail beaucoup de
bruit des travaux tous les côtés en tout
cas moi qui vit en ville c'est comme ça
et là et à rien il n'y a pas de bruit et
c'est vraiment ce que je recherche donc
c'est vraiment ce qui m'a intéressé que
ce produit que je trouve très très
intéressant alors je vais t'expliquer
d'un produit technologique comment ça
marche
si vous êtes familier de google paul
vous savez qu'à la technologie sixième
sens lille et du sixième sens c'est une
machine intelligente qui va vous aider
dans votre linge si vous avez un four ça
va vous aider à la cuisson moi j'ai
aussi un lave-vaisselle ça va m'aider
pour optimiser le lavage de la vaisselle
on est donc dans l'idée du sixième sens
quelque chose d'intuitif quelque chose d
facile vous embêtez pas nous fait
confiance à la chine elle a elle même
ses propres compétences et elle va vous
faire le job parfaitement bien par
exemple et si vous avez un algorithme
dans votre machine
les eaux du sixième sens qui va pouvoir
calculer le pouvoir d'absorption de
l'eau selon votre type de linge et qui
va c'est pour déterminer le poids de
votre linge en fonction des rotations en
début de cycle et ce qui est plutôt
intéressante et elle va continuer
l'analyse et pendant tout le cycle du
lavage ça vous permettra de faire des
économies d'eau de temps d'électricité
et d'optimiser complètement le lavage de
votre linge sans abîmer vos tissus
en gros si l'ag déjà mouillé utilisera
beaucoup
jouffre et donc des économies en
fabrique sainte ok vraiment intelligent
le deuxième point qu'intéressante
technologie zen le moteur zen
il s'agit d'un moteur la transmission
directe qu'il a supprimé les vibrations
va donc supprimer le bruit qui vous
permet donc de réduire significativement
le bruit pendant le lavage et pendant
les orages
en plus de ça dans la machine vous avez
une isolation phonique qui n'est donc
pas passé le bruit qu on également la
technologie pre-season clean c'est un
système d'injection directe de l'eau
plus du détergent directement dans votre
machine grâce à une douchette haute
pression vous avez ces technologies soft
move qui vous permet une bonne
distribution du village et un séchage
parfait alors on pourrait se dire on est
sur un lave-linge y a rien de bien
technologique ibm en vous voyez
justement que c'est un produit qui est
technologique un produit où il ya plein
de techno des techno qui sont là pour
vous faciliter la vie
pour optimiser le lavage de votre linge
pour éviter justement de l'endommager
pour s'adapter à votre typologie de
tissus en fonction de ce que vous allez
l'ag et surtout qui va s'adapter à votre
vie à votre mode de vie en étant
extrêmement silencieuses ou en tout cas
j'apprécie je souffre c'est intéressant
ça fait quelques semaines maintenant que
j'utilise quelques semaines qu'elle est
ici qu elle est à côté que j'ai
justement l'habitude de tourner avec ce
la plage à côté
et puis vous assurer que je me pose plus
la question de me dire il faut que je
garde mon linge
ah bah non pas parce que là j'ai atteint
un débit aux attentes qu'est-ce qu'il
faut que je tourne aujourd'hui il faut
que je tourne ça j'ai ça alors je peux
lancer à telle heure oui mais si je le
lance là à quel moment je vais pouvoir
l'étendre parce qu'il va rester dedans
ça va pas le faire je pose plus la
question jamais plus dès que j'ai besoin
je me lève je vais dedans je le sors je
les temps je peux travailler en même
temps pour moi c'est vraiment un bien au
niveau la qualité de mon travail si
toutefois ce lave-linge arrivé chez vous
ça pouvait être un gain de qualité de
vie chez vous pas de nuisances sonores
pratique rapide du linge qu'elle avait
de bonnes conditions
et ça c'est vraiment cool on laissera
des lave-linge les plus silencieux du
marché à 66 décibels faut savoir qu'un
téléphone qui vibre c'est 76 décibels
une bouilloire 77 décibels autant de
dire que vous êtes franchement en
dessous voilà pour ce retour
d'expérience je les partage avec vous
justement vous avez un peu dans les
coulisses je monte des choses que je
vous montrerai pas autrement
je souhaite que vous serez probablement
pas amené à revoir mon repas vous
montrez votre lave-linge derrière dans
le studio
en tout cas voyez c'est très drôle des
fois comme on voit les coulisses comme
on se rend compte qu'il ya qu'on a nous
aussi nos deux problématiques devront y
retourner cette vidéo le lave linge
le studio réussir à combler tous à la
vie familiale l'environnement plus
professionnel voilà un petit peu pour
ses petits secrets aujourd'hui dites
nous ce que vous en pensez est ce que ça
vous intéresse que je vous parle des
lecteurs
l'ag qu'est ce que vous pensez de ce
lave-linge whirpool suprême caire
extrêmement zen extrêmement silencieuse
que vous trouvez ça intéressant est ce
que ça vous intéresse et que vous parle
justement est bien de plus de coulisses
ici dans le studio pouvoir vous parler
pourquoi pas plus électro ménagers dites
moi tout ça on va en commentaire quant à
nous on retrouve dès demain sur ce je
vous embrasse
mais il ya demain ciao